welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and black widow left us with the
mystery of the red guardian alexis
shostakov who loves telling his war
stories about captain america back in
the 80s i have the nuclear call
but there he is
captain
[Music]
what year was this i don't know 98 384
and if you were to remind him cap was a
popsicle from 1945 to 2011
he'll make your wrist perfect for
stealing stickers out of vending
machines
such was the fate of his fellow inmate
ursa aka
big bear who by the way was just
confirmed by the actor
to be the russian mutant ursa major who
can transform into a huge brown bear he
joined crimson dynamo on the winter
guard
that's fun but anyway it seemed alexi
was just lying
but then after escaping he continues to
badger natasha
asking if steve ever talked about him
did he talk to you about him
who what are you talking about captain
america my great adversary in this
theater of geopolitical conflict not so
much a
nemesis more like a contemporary you
know but between steve's frozen status
and alexi being imprisoned for several
years up until that point there really
was no
overlap in which either of them could
have met so why does he keep bringing it
up
is alexi delusional most likely david
harbour said in an interview
jokingly at first that alexi's cap
stories are quote absolutely true 100
but that alexi wasn't interested in
reality he doesn't even know that he's
lying however
i can report after thoroughly
researching the history of both the mcu
and the comics that there are actually
four ways the red guardian could be
telling the truth
about having fought captain america in
the year 1984.
real quick thanks to kiwiko for
sponsoring today's video more about them
later by the way we still have some
great black widow inspired merch options
at newrockstarsmirch.com including our
awesome latest obsession the red deep
shirt a russian nesting doll shirt and
this awesome red ledger notebook get em
all supplies last ain't gonna last long
thank you for your cooperation why did i
do that so let us first get out of the
way the theory that alexi could have
faced isaiah bradley
nope i'm sorry folks it'd be awesome to
see those two fight i'd put my money on
isaiah but the problem was isaiah was
100 not
active during the 1980s he fought during
the korean war which lasted from 1950 to
as that war was coming to an end he was
imprisoned by the american government
for 30 years according to him now that
would have put him out in enough time to
face alexi in the year 1984
but isaiah said that he was only
released because a nurse declared him
dead and that ever since he's been
laying low in baltimore hoping that the
government would never find out that he
was still alive
and as one of the many black super
soldier test subjects he was cruelly
denied the title of captain america so
he's definitely not the cap that alexi
was referring to
but the cap succession that we saw in
the falcon winter soldier from john
walker to sam wilson actually began
in the comics with a handful of other
captain americas throughout the decades
so our mystery mcu 80s cap could be
a past cap successor see in the comics
after cap disappears into the ice the
american public actually believed that
cap
endured when men by the name of william
neslund
and then jeffrey mace took over the cat
mantle but when mace retired another guy
named william burnside who grew up
obsessed with steve rogers returned from
germany with a formula for the super
soldier serum which used his leverage to
become the new cap he actually changed
his name to steve rogers and altered his
voice and got plastic surgery to look
more like steve rogers
yikes yeah surprise surprise not the
best guy actually his serum was faulty
and later on in his life he tried to
overthrow the government
so burnside could be our 80s cap but
there's actually a likelier cap
successor that's already in the mcu
roscoe simons in the comics simons takes
over the cat mantle from steve rogers
after roger steps down to become nomad
cap simons actually faces the red skull
and gets tortured and publicly crucified
to send a message to steve rogers and
technically roscoe simons exists in the
mcu
steve wore his uniform at camp lehigh in
1970 in avengers end game so this young
soldier could have stepped up into the
cap title
as part of some reboot initiative in the
following decade
and been the cat that alexi fought in
1984 but let's not forget that steve
rogers is technically still alive in the
mcu and depending on how you interpret
the final scene of avengers in-game he
himself
could have actually fought the red
guardian because of time travel kiwiko
is defining the future of play by making
it engaging and richie and seriously fun
kiwiko offers eight subscription lines
each catering to different age groups
designed to expose kids to concepts in
steam
science technology engineering art and
math they believe in the concept of
small today big tomorrow
teach kids problem solving on small
projects today and who knows what they
can accomplish in the future so this is
the tinker crate that they sent me this
month shows you how to build these uh
cool little friction climbers
it was awesome putting these together
look how this sloth climbs he's moving
way faster than a normal sloth would i
actually learned a lot and let's just
say i'm on the north end of their nine
years old and up range for the tinker
box but hey i still had a blast
kiwico wants kids to be fearless
innovators and design projects to help
them develop that muscle
you can get 50 off your first month of
any crate by going to kiwico.com
new rockstars linked below in the
description now if you go by the
screenwriter's explanation that cap went
back in time to the 1940s and lived his
life with peggy carter
in the background of the mcu that we
have been watching then alexi could have
fought
host endgame steve rogers in the same
timeline that would mean that there was
a second cap in mcu history who fought
in the shadows helping history in some
ways but staying out of it weirdly in
others like letting jfk get assassinated
letting 911 happen don't think too hard
about it but if alexi's mission involved
freaking stolen nuclear codes as he says
perhaps that was one mission that this
steve rogers could not stay out of so he
confronted alexi but in a way that made
him think that he was successful or
maybe he would have been an older man
alexie could have had the upper hand
against in a fight as he claimed and
since that this steve was living his
life in secret
no one would believe alexi when he told
others this story in 2016 natasha and
steve would have no idea what alexi was
talking about but despite the tva's
apparent double standards about variants
and nexus events i still believe the
director's explanation that steve rogers
actually lived his life with peggy in an
alternate branch history and then later
he returned the mcu timeline as an old
man to hand off the shield to sam wilson
so that presents the option that alexi
actually could have fought
post-end game steve rogers from an
alternate timeline like imagine if steve
could travel across timelines as an old
man to hand off that shield
perhaps he could have made a similar
journey just back to the year 1984 to
face alexi
in whatever this mission was that
involved nuclear codes i bring this up
because there have been reports that
marvel studios is developing future
films with chris evans as steve rogers
and if so presumably it would be with
evan's but not an old man makeup
suggesting it would take place in an
alternate history so we may see chris
evans cap in that fight with a red
guardian after all or the way loki left
things
maybe the events of black widow are even
taking place in that alternate timeline
i know i know these alternate timeline
explanations are a bit
convoluted so the actual truth and the
reason alexi may struggle with the truth
of his own history
could reflect the way his government has
treated him and that alexis fight with
caps
may have been faked by the ussr now
remember from the ant-man movie
in the year 1987 separatists hijacked a
soviet missile silo in kursk that's a
russian city near the border of
present-day ukraine and the separatists
launched an icbm at the united states
a huge freaking deal that crisis may
have been the result of
years of soviet instability over its
nuclear grid which could have included
the
misplacement of nuclear codes so they
needed to send in the red guardian to
recover them
as a propaganda cover story they could
have thrown against alexi a patsy
captain america for him to defeat
so the soviets could save face and claim
this is all some botched american
operation
now my gut tells me that alexi was just
lying but again for him to keep bringing
up cap even when he's out of prison
tells me that he experienced something
whether he fought an 80s cap successor
like william burnside or roscoe simon's
steve rogers after the events of
avengers
end game either in this timeline or in a
different one or if he fought a patsy
his government used to lie to him i'd
leave that up to you
comment down below with your theories
and again check out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow and subscribe to new
rockstars thanks for watching those
[Music]
you